What's up guys!
I'm Noah.
I'm Laura.
And I'm Odiseas.
And we're about to something that we've never
done publicly before.
Read out loud the craziest stuff we have in
our notes app on our phones or IPads.
So, are you ready?
What you got, what you got?
This is October 1st 2014.
I said we are what we create and we create
what we are.
That is so Noah, Noah has literally not changed.
And there's, If one defines wealth by dollars
and cents my resources to aid and replenishment
are awfully limited, but if devotion and sense
typifies one's concept of rich, then I've
got indef...
In...in...
Heaps of...
Well now I feel like I can't read either!
It's a J. Cole lyric!
Please read this one.
Do not file income tax.
There's all these deep ones, and then literally...
I'm sweating so much right now!
Did you listen to that note?
Yeah.
I think it must have been for school.
September 14, 2013.
So number 1, how old?
And then I put 20s.
Then number 2, music.
Disco was big at UCLA Bell bottoms, platform
shoes.
Three, politics.
Nixon then Carter
He used the word "vietnamization"
Watergate happened.
I'm a terrible note taker.
Watergate happened!
Trusting, topanga canyon walk, P.
This was for a school project.
It is literally how I ended it.
Note to yourself right now, my note is an
old bio of myself.
March 28, 2012.
Singer, actor, Odiseas hails from Ghana, West
Africa where his, its just like telling my
life, blah blah blah.
I like that.
Ghana, West Africa where he was born in the
city of Tema.
His mother is Ghanian and his father is Grecian.
The fifteen year old currently lives with
his mother and step father, oh my God...
Who he states is Odiseas' real dad, because
he raised him along with his three brothers
in Brooklyn, New York.
Yo that's a long ass note, my dude!
My bio is not like that anymore!
I have a bunch of weird ones, I definitely
don't use this app the way it should, so I
just write one sentence and then leave.
What you got?
I got this one note, that says Romance never
goes unpunished.
Romance never goes unpunished!
Fire.
This was, ok these were notes from a book
called Seat of the Soul.
I love that book.
Yeah!
This is and interesting one.
I feel like that's kind of an acting one.
Interesting how the shifting of distance of
focus of my eyes can tell the story of a thought
of recognition.
Or maybe not.
Of course!
No, it's true
though, yeah yeah yeah, like if we're sitting
here and we're talking and I'm engaging with
the camera and I have to think of something,
I shift my focus to a little bit like here,
and I'm all the sudden thinking of something-
And not really listening and engaging-
And my focus is somewhere really, like here.
Nuts!
So this is from December 4, 2015, definitely
a school one.
Arnold claims that if the Supreme Court continues
to make decisions like Rodriguez vs United
States police misconduct will soon become
much more limited, and then I have an Instagram
account, @crystal_fagle.
I don't know if this is the weirdest, I have
a few weird ones.
My homemade toothpaste recipe:
Organic cold pressed coconut oil, good aluminum
free baking soda, 100% cacao powder, peppermint
essential oil, oil of oregano.
Wow!
And then I have a next note that says, Howl
like a wolf before songs.
As advice to myself.
That's cool.
Yo, yo you gotta get a high speed camera to
check out his mouth while he does that, like.
True!
His lips vibrate!
Pretty epic.
Really?
Yeah yeah yeah, very cool.
Sick!
Shopping lists.
Alright, I have one.
This was a note taken May 4th, 2017.
I said two mushrooms, $1.79 each.
Four avocados, stickers off, 57 cents each.
One can tomato sauce, $2.97 each.
And then, space space space.
Then, space space space, probiotics.
Gotta keep that gut right.
I like avocados with no sticker.
Yeah, what up with that?
Why no sticker?
I don't really know why I said that, maybe
because I didn't wanna spend the time unsticking
it.
That's true.
Yeah.
You could also just not worry about it and
cut it.
And just cut it.
Exactly.
I have a weird one.
June 22, 2017, at 9:23 AM.
I have, Avenos, and then I have the word Tusk.
Is there something at the grocery store or
CVS that you would get that's called Tusk?
I hope it's not elephants.
We don't like that.
Mine says Sonic R toothbrush, and what I meant
to write was Sonicaire toothbrush, tongue
cleaner.
You're very into your own, cleaning your mouth.
You gotta keep your mouth clean, bro.
Bro, you ever use a tongue cleaner?
No.
Yooooo.
They got these metal things and they're like,
they just look like a U, and you scrape all
of this stuff off.
Really?
I just got it at the dentist.
Where can I find this?
CVS.
Newest notes. What you got for us?
This was February 18, but I update it all
the time, so I guess it's a little bit closer,
but its links to my new songs so I have it
in the notes app, so when I have to post the
links I don't have to go to my email and do
everything.
I got one if you want me to take it.
Yeah yeah yeah, ok.
It's, it's one sentence it says Solace became
his chains.
Smooth.
You said one thing when we were working that
you read in someone's office.
Oh my God.
That you said it changed your life, but it
kinda changed mine.
This set off a full blown panic attack.
Do you remember what it said?
I was in a meeting and I was sitting there
talking to this guy, and I look over and on
one of his shelves there's just this little
rectangular sign that said, What you avoid,
controls you.
Like, crazy.
I like that you have Yay.
Yay.
So this is a song lyric, March 1, 2019, Do
you and imma do me.
That's all I got right there.
Great.
Did you use it while were were filming the
movie for writing the break up speech?
Do you remember this?
Absolutely.
So I just pulled out my notes and I started
writing reasons why I need to break up with
Laura.
It was like Shakespearian sonnets.
The burning depths of my soul, for like-
That was low key it, yeah.
Really intense.
We're the cast of The Perfect Date.
Boom.